politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisodes 246 ce
soir mon invité et le maire de carrière
sous Poissy et dit à
[Musique]
opolitique
et bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous avez été pendant longtemps
membre du Parti radical de gauche avant
de le quitter en 2017 aujourd'hui vous
vous qualifiez de maire écologistes sans
étiquette alors vous avez été longtemps
conseillé régional d'Île-de-France sur
une liste de gauche et vous avez soutenu
Emmanuel Macron en tout cas pour vous
avez appelé à voter pour lui lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vu le contexte on est
plus d'un an après cette élection vous
regrettez votre soutien alors d'abord je
suis effectivement en mer sans étiquette
dans la mesure où je n'appartiens plus à
aucune formation politique aujourd'hui
de plus de cinq années maintenant voir 7
et je suis classé par la préfecture la
liste que j'ai conduite aux élections
municipales étaient classées divers
écologistes de par sa composition mais
aussi la présidence du groupe écologiste
que je que j'assumais au concert
régional d'Île-de-France où j'étais
alors élu en 2020 j'ai fait un choix qui
était pour moi un choix de
responsabilité de refuser les extrêmes
et de choisir
le camp de celui qui prenait une
construction européenne intelligente et
qui avait fait la démonstration que nous
pouvions gérer une crise sanitaire d'une
manière intelligente la France a eu la
chance d'avoir des vaccins des masques
d'avoir la chance d'avoir un appareil
d'État qui s'est mobilisé d'avoir
l'organisation de centre de dépistage
dans les communes de vaccinations
ensuite et donc j'ai fait ce choix en
raison mais ma liste étant une liste
plurielle j'avais aussi pris
l'engagement de ne pas Rainer aucun
candidat mais j'avais fait le choix en
responsabilité d'indiquer ce qu'elle
allait être ma ma décision personnelle
et dès l'époque j'avais émis un certain
nombre de réserves mais que ce choix
était celui non pas par défaut parce
qu'il faut jamais dire ça en politique
mais un choix qui était pour moi
vraiment celui qui était nécessaire et
utile au moment où je l'ai fait vous
connaissez mon engagement pour la
condition animale ou qu'on essaie mon
engagement pour l'écologie je peux pas
dire que un an après je sois totalement
satisfait des orientations qui qui ont
été prises mais de la même manière je
n'ai pas souscrit au programme du
président de la République j'ai fait le
choix de de défendre d'abord la
la République et ce qu'elle portait dans
cette élection qui était
particulièrement tendue qui prenait une
tonalité qui ne qui ne me plaisait pas
au regard de la nécessité pour chacune
et pour chacun de prendre sa part de de
responsabilité d'assumer sa charge de
citoyenneté donc non le bilan pour moi
n'est pas n'est pas celui que j'aurais
souhaité néanmoins il faut reconnaître
un certain nombre de choses positives je
pense sur l'Europe notamment la manière
dont la France a pris le lead sur la
gestion de la crise ukrainienne en
essayant de défendre un modèle de
d'armée européenne ou en essayant de
défendre une Europe plus intégrée
quelque chose qui va dans le dans le bon
sens l'Europe justement où c'était l'un
des axes qui vous avez séduit en tout
cas chez Emmanuel Macron le seul
candidat qui porte l'Europe avec
enthousiasme vous aviez dit il y a
maintenant plus d'un an les députés ont
récemment voté l'obligation pour les
mères des communes de plus de 2500
habitants d'arborer le drapeau européen
à côté du drapeau français certains élus
se sont agacés face à cette volonté
expliquant qu'il y avait des choses plus
importantes actuellement pour vous
est-ce que cette loi reste un symbole
fort en tout cas la France et l'Europe
les deux drapeaux côte à côte je pense
qu'il est important que la France assume
ça la place qui est la sienne dans
l'Europe ça passe par des actes
politiques formes ça passe aussi par des
symboles c'est pas que c'est c'est pas
qu'il existe des choses plus importantes
que de mettre le drapeau c'est important
aussi de mettre le drapeau européen je
sais pas s'il fallait contraindre
carrière sous Poissy ça fait bientôt
plus de 15 ans que le drapeau européen
dans la plupart
c'est quelque chose d'assez naturelles
les équipements publics en mairie la
ville célébrée toute l'Europe tout au
long du mois de mai nous étions encore
récemment avec les ressortissants
européens résidents à carrière sous
Poissy à l'hôtel de ville pour une
réception à leur honneur donc nous
faisons vraiment de par un ADN des
communes en général et de carrière sous
Poissy en particulier donc c'est bien
que le drapeau européen flotte au fond
ton des mairies ce débat aurait dû être
peut-être l'occasion de renouer avec un
certain idéal européen et d'amener ça
avec plus de de finesse peut-être dans
le débat public voilà maintenant la
caricature a été a été faite par les
populistes qui eux voient le drapeau
européen comme si c'était un drapeau
d'occupation enfin c'est quelque chose
d'assez fou quand même dans un an ce
sera le 9 juin 2024 les élections
européennes auront lieu la gauche ne
s'est pas encore si elle fera liste
commune il faut dire que les projets
européens sont parfois différents entre
LFI Europe écologie des verts ou encore
le PS avec quel projet européen vous
vous sentez le plus proche on vient de
parler d'Europe à l'instant d'abord moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour celles et
ceux qui militent à gauche aujourd'hui
qui porte une voie de l'opposition
seulement moi je laisse les parties de
gauche à leur turpitude et là c'est un
capacité à pouvoir s'entendre sur un
modèle européen parce que une
informations déciderait que l'Europe
incarne une part du mal de notre
quotidien ce n'est pas possible pour des
partis qui ont été profondément
européens donc moi je me positionnerai
sur un projet européen qui sera clair
ambitieux enthousiaste et qui ira vers
plus d'Europe plus d'Europe intégrés
plus de politique publique européenne
efficace pour une robe de la défense
pour une Europe qui nous permet de
relever les défis de du changement
climatique aujourd'hui j'attends de voir
ce qui se prononce ce qui se prononcera
et ce qui se présentera
à l'électeurs vous avez des exemples
concrets d'aide de l'Union européenne
pour votre ville carrière sous Poissy
oui alors déjà vous avez un bel espace
naturel sensible qui le parc
départemental du Peuple de l'Herbe donc
j'irai par le Conseil départemental des
Yvelines qui investit près de 30
millions dans la commune et qui t'imparc
qui est labellisé life plus par la
Commission européenne par sa qualité
environnementale et pour cela il y a eu
plus d'un million d'euros versés par la
Commission européenne vous avez
également
la fabrique 21 qui est un hôtel
surprise pour les éco-constructeurs
fabriqués par des éco-constructeurs qui
a également la bénéficié de fonds
européens je pense également à une
partie de la réhabilitation de l'exploit
de maraîchère de Carrières-sous-Poissy
le cœur vert ça fasse un qu'a aussi
profité de fonds européens et puis nos
jeunes qui peuvent profiter de la
mobilité professionnelle ou la mobilité
étudiante avec les programmes eras plus
notamment et donc pour moi c'est une
évidence l'Europe sur les territoires et
d'ailleurs je me fier de carrière
maintenant soit reconnu comme étant
membre du réseau bâtir l'Europe avec les
élus locaux on a récemment dévoilé une
plaque là-dessus c'est un réseau auquel
la ville participe désormais et dont je
suis le représentant auprès de la
Commission européenne donc c'est plutôt
une belle fierté pour carrière sous
pression les agressions envers les élus
on refait malheureusement la une de
l'actualité récemment avec le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins en
Loire-Atlantique yannick morrèze a vu sa
maison incendiée alors qu'il avait
accepté d'accueillir un centre de
réfugiés dans sa commune ce n'est
malheureusement pas la première fois
la seule le seul exemple en tout cas de
violence envers les élus locaux qui
croient depuis donc c'est c'est des
exemples de violence croient depuis la
crise sanitaire vous en avez vous-même
fait l'expérience en 2021 menacé et
insulter par un citoyen ça touche au
moral j'imagine pour la suite du mandat
d'abord redire tout le monde soutien mon
collègue mère un café l'objet de si
forts intimidation avec l'incendie de sa
maison lui dire que c'est un vrai drame
ceux qu'il a vécu et que en partie je
regrette sa décision d'abandonner son
mandat mais je comprends sa famille sa
propre sécurité doit rester la priorité
même si je regrette qu'on soit pas
capable de protéger les élus dans ce
pays correctement puisqu'il se sentent
en danger c'est que quelque part le
travail n'est pas fait suffisamment j'ai
effectivement pu être
menacé à plusieurs reprises ou intimidé
moi je considère que ça ne m'arrête pas
bien au contraire qu'il nous faut encore
convaincre davantage mais c'est vrai
qu'on sent dans une société en général
une violence qui s'est installée elle
peut être morale psychologique verbal et
parfois physique et c'est ce passage à
l'acte là qui est plutôt inquiétant
parce qu'il est de plus en plus
important ce passage à l'acte et donc
c'est un pas trop mon moral ça plutôt
renforcer ma détermination à se dire que
j'ai une responsabilité à remettre les
choses un peu dans l'ordre avec d'autres
collègues mer voilà en tout cas pas
l'intention je le dis à mon opposition
démissionner parce que la tendance est
un peu compliqué en France aujourd'hui
non je plaisante mais je sincèrement je
pense qu'il faut tenir bon il faut
rester à la barre du navire et continuer
à servir avec intérêt en réponse à cette
démission la ministre Dominique Faure au
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales à annoncé la
création d'un centre d'analyse et de
lutte contre les atteintes aux élus le
vice-président de la session des maires
d'Île-de-France le maire de Mennecy
Jean-Philippe dugouin Clément a déclaré
que c'était du bullshit vous partagez
son avis
la ministre Dominique Faure prend la
mesure qu'elle juge nécessaire je pense
que c'est pas c'est pas ça le sujet
aujourd'hui on a besoin de de rétablir
l'autorité républicaine d'une manière
opérationnelle avec des moyens mais
aussi d'une manière
philosophique c'est à dire que la
République c'est pas c'est pas un modèle
institutionnel c'est un projet politique
et donc on a failli sur la manière de
tenir une partie de ses promesses de
l'égalité de l'accès à l'emploi du du
cadre de vie de la défense de
l'environnement donc il faut restaurer
une partie du cadre républicain pour
redonner confiance et faire abaisser
l'attention et puis il faut qu'on ait
aussi une justice plus efficace c'est à
dire il faut l'application
l'applicabilité des peines soit plus
forte aujourd'hui dans notre dans notre
pays alors je sais pas si la mesure de
la ministre c'est du bullshit mais je
comprends ce que veut dire Jean-Philippe
Dugoin Clément qui est par ailleurs un
ami que c'est pas la réponse immédiate
attendue enfin voilà il faut réa
l'autorité républicaine dans notre pays
ça passe comme je vous le disais par des
moyens supplémentaires mais aussi par un
cap qui est redonné notre pays a besoin
d'un récit narratif renouvelé alors
justement le gouvernement visageait
d'accentuer les sanctions dans une
future loi qui sera présentée au
Parlement on pourrait désormais risquer
la même chose si on agresse un élu que
si l'on agresse un policier vous
trouverez ça normal alors il y a déjà
une évolution il y a quelques temps
puisque aujourd'hui insulter un élu
n'est considéré comme un outrage donc la
peine est déjà renforcée donc mais
pourquoi pas mais mais voyez bien que
l'escalade dans la dans la force de la
mesure n'est pas la solution on a un
arsenal législatif Arsenal pénal en
France qui est très fort très élevé la
question c'est sa mise en oeuvre et je
pense sincèrement qui ont manque
aujourd'hui de cette de cette présence
de l'autorité en proximité qui rappelle
les règles du vivre ensemble je rejoins
pour le coup les propos du président de
la République le terme assez fort qu'il
a utilisé de
des civilisations sur l'état de la
société je pense qu'il a en partie
raison on est un tournant et on doit
faire attention à ce que ça ne glisse
pas davantage le mariage homosexuel a
fêté ses 10 ans la loi était adoptée
officiellement le 17 mai 2013 à l'époque
les débats étaient vifs pour préparer
cette mission j'ai retrouvé un extrait
donc qui date du 10 octobre 2012 à
l'époque vous débattiez sur TV 78 avec
le maire du Chesnay qui annonçait lui
refusait de célébrer les mariages
homosexuels si la loi passait écoutez
faut trouver une autre solution sinon on
va sortir dans la rue et on fera non pas
les pigeons mais on fera les aigles qui
iront à Paris pour faire rejeter cette
loi et vous verrez qu'on se mobilisera
et si la loi passe si elle est votée si
elle est acceptée vous l'appliquerez non
personnellement je ferai jouer la clause
morale et je ne marierai pas
les principes de la République j'ai pas
envie j'ai pas dit ça si nous avons pris
une motion c'est pour dire avant le
texte de loi que nous émettons les plus
grandes réserves en tant que médecin je
n'étais pas favorable à l'avortement on
peut pas obliger aujourd'hui avortement
je vois qu'il y a un texte qui va
obliger tous les hôpitaux à avoir aussi
cette obligation il faut arrêter la
démocratie c'est aussi de respecter les
autres et je demande à la gauche de nous
respecter dans chaque commune chaque mer
adapte le Code civil adapte les lois un
petit peu à sa sauce ça va devenir un
petit peu compliqué aussi
on se marier à carrière je pense qu'il
faut être un petit peu sérieux si ce
n'est pas dans le cadre du débat qui est
le nôtre tout d'abord on parle pas d'une
loi mais d'une loi qui va porter réforme
du Code civil un risque qui a fait
l'objet de nombreuses réformes je
rappelle quand même que le mariage et la
famille ne sont pas des institutions
naturelles mais des institutions
sociales et qu'il est très régulièrement
adapté ces textes et je sais pas il
pense ce qu'il veut moi je pense
aujourd'hui ce qu'est la réalité des
faits présentée et portée par une
majorité Parlement c'est des propos
dédié
encore et vous aurez le temps d'y
répondre en mélangeant un certain nombre
de genres ce que je veux dire ici c'est
que toutes les sociétés qui ont adopté
ces nouvelles
dispositions le droit à l'adoption le
droit au mariage non pas terminé dans un
déclin absolu comme nous le promettent
je ne sais quelle fanatique religieux ou
qu'elle relève d'opinion qui perdent la
place qui est la leur en confondant les
lieux de la République qui sont et le
relais d'opinion de différentes pensées
intégristes et je les invite vraiment à
se recadrer très rapidement sur le débat
et à ne pas oublier qu'un élu de la
République est là pour faire appliquer
la loi et que si Monsieur le Maire du
Chesnay a le droit de pas donner le
mariage il doit s'assurer qu'un adjoint
par délégation le fasse des débats
tendus comme vous avez pu l'entendre 10
ans et 70 000 mariages homosexuels plus
tard vous estimez avoir convaincu et
gagner ce débat dans l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est extrait
nous ramène effectivement des années en
arrière je me rappelle beaucoup de
souvenirs la lutte la
côté de convaincre aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité c'est installé dans le paysage
législative du pays la question de
savoir si un maire ou pas ne Marie pas
ne se pose plus elle se pose plus à
Monsieur Briot qui n'est plus maire par
ailleurs donc voilà ça a été un moment
très dur il faut le reconnaître ou
beaucoup de gens ont souffert des propos
qui ont été tenus dans les rues ça fait
resurgir une forme d'homophobie dans
notre pays qui existe toujours
aujourd'hui contre laquelle il faut
lutter moi je rappelle que l'homophobie
comme le l'antisémitisme ou le racisme
n'est pas une opinion c'est un délit
c'est condamné par le code pénal et
qu'on a le droit de pas être un militant
de la cause LGBT mais ça ne vous donne
pas le droit d'être homophobe raciste ou
antisémite donc c'est ça la République
c'est cette promesse d'égalité et je
pense que ce qu'on appelle le mariage
homosexuel est en fait un mariage pour
tous car ce qui permettait à certains
qui en était exclus
d'en bénéficier et c'est vraiment la
force de nos textes et de ce beau Code
civil qui aujourd'hui est lu dans toutes
les mairies de France
tous les élus de toutes les tendances
politiques pour marier des couples
hétérosexuels ou homosexuels alors
justement si on regarde le dernier
rapport sur les LGBTI phobie 2023 de SOS
Homophobie il dresse un constat alarmant
en tout 184 donc
d'entrée ont été recensés par
l'association en 2022 ça représente une
agression homophobe ou transphobes tous
les deux jours plus 27% par rapport à
2022 le combat continue encore ce n'est
pas encore totalement gagné selon vous
on a vu aussi cette campagne pour la
Ligue 1 le championnat de foot qui a
fait polémique le combat pour l'égalité
il s'arrêtera jamais enfin il n'y a pas
vocation à disparaître puisqu'il y a
toujours une nécessité à être vigilant
et à garantir que chacune et chacun dans
sa diversité soit respecté c'est vrai
que j'ai été profondément moi assez
blessé par le débat autour de la Ligue 1
du refus de certains joueurs de porter
le brassard arc-en-ciel
parce que ce qui était anecdotique avec
quelques joueurs seulement devient
maintenant un discours
militant ou un joueur
s'autorise à dire que il a rien contre
la diversité et la joie de vie de
certains mais qu'à l'inverse on doit
respecter sa décision personnelle basée
sur sa pratique religieuse bah ça ça
n'est pas possible ce qu'on lui demande
pas d'être homosexuel ou d'être militant
de je ne sais quelle cause en portant un
brassage mais de réaffirmer un
engagement de la Ligue et du club auquel
il appartient et donc du sport en partie
en général et du foot en particulier que
c'est un sport qui refuse les
discriminations et l'homophobie et ces
champs homophobes scandés dans les
stades sont pour moi à chaque fois des
insultes et je regrette là dessus que
des médias encore continuer diffuser des
des des matchs où on entend encore ses
propos-movent et je regrette la
faiblesse des mesures qui sont prises
même si on a une ministre des Sports
là-dessus très sensible très engagé je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin parce
que le sport et le foot vraiment c'est
un modèle pour beaucoup de nos jeunes
c'est un modèle où exacerbe un peu cette
virilité
excessive et qui font que parfois il met
dans la tête d'un certain nombre de nos
de nos jeunes et confort des discours
d'adultes comme quoi il serait normal de
rejeter l'autre parce qu'il est
différent sur tel ou tel point donc je
pense qu'il y a encore un gros travail à
faire et que le sport peut être un beau
un beau véhicule de conviction même si
la majorité des cas les choses se
passent bien mais c'est vrai que j'ai
une pensée pour tous ces jeunes qui se
ouvrent et n'oublions pas quand même que
les tentatives de suicide chez les chez
les jeunes qui sont LGBT sont très
largement supérieurs aux actes aux
pourcentage dans notre société quoi et
pour cette dernière partie d'émission on
va parler de la de l'actualité à
carrière sous Poissy
[Musique]
toujours avec Eddie haït ce soir dans
l'herbe de politique maire de carrière
sous Poissy de 2008 à 2014 et depuis
2020 donc ville de moins de 20 000
habitants vous avez lancé ce mercredi
une consultation citoyenne sur l'avenir
de la plaine maraîchère un lieu se
trouvait jusqu'en 2020 la plus grande
décharge à ciel ouvert de France on l'a
surnommé la mère de déchets alors
pourquoi ces déchets avaient été
entreposés là et comment est-ce que vous
avez fait ensuite pour les faire
disparaître en fait de 2015 à fin 2019
les 330 hectares que constituent
la plaine qui constitue la pleine
maraîchère de Carrières-sous-Poissy
l'exploit de maraîchère autrefois source
de prospérité locale pour le par
l'agriculture était devenu un espace
vide ouvert et s'est organisé un réseau
de dépôts de déchets d'entreprise de PME
d'industriels qui plutôt que de
travailler sur la valorisation le
recyclage des déchets comme la loi lui
oblige venez ici déverser leurs déchets
donc des milliers de mètres cubes se
sont entreposés et donc grâce à l'action
du Conseil départemental mais également
à la mobilisation des élus locaux et
puis des citoyens des de ces vigiles
citoyennes
nettoiement a pu être engagé on parle de
nettoiement compte tenu de la masse que
ça représentait le département investi
avec l'État plusieurs millions d'euros
et je le remercie vraiment le Conseil
départemental parce que honnêtement 107
acteur local la mère de déchets ne
serait sûrement pas
n'aurait sûrement pas disparu
aujourd'hui donc se poser la question de
savoir ce que nous allions faire de ce
bel espace et de cette aménagement enfin
à venir donc on a décidé de créer une
commission extra-municipale en 2020 de
mettre au travail un certain d'experts
d'associations de citoyens et d'élus et
de produire un rapport un peu plus de
100 pages 12 orientations d'aménagement
confrontés aux avantages aux
inconvénients au financement possible
qui sont désormais
soumis à consultation citoyenne et donc
on est plutôt fier de cette démarche qui
est assez inédite sur la ville qui a été
fait avec les moyens internes sur la
base des contributions intellectuelles
de chacune et de chacun et donc
maintenant voilà qu'on s'est local de la
jeunesse comité de quartier habitant
association anciens
plus jeune chacun vient contribuer et
donne une part de sa réflexion pour
hiérarchiser ses orientations qui seront
après donner aux parties prenantes au
maître d'oeuvre aux décisions au
décideurs alors justement ce rapport a
été publié cette semaine quels sont
aujourd'hui les possibilités d'avenir
pour cette plaine alors il y a la
volonté parmi les hypothèses
d'aménagement de réintroduire une forme
d'agriculture en prenant en compte la
pollution 3 orientations sont proposées
là-dessus vos possibilités aussi de
travailler sur une ferme pédagogique
avec un parcours patrimonial la volonté
également de créer une fabrique 21 du
vélo de faire de ces grands espaces un
lieu de d'apprentissage de développement
de la partie cycliste un lieu de
ressourcerie autour du vélo la volonté
aussi de développer la question de la
cause animale avec l'éventualité de
l'implantation à centre d'éducation
canine la possibilité de faire de la
plaine un puits de carbone et
divers autres projets qui viennent comme
ça conforter une vocation si vous voulez
agricole écologique paysagère et il faut
rester de cette plaine qui est
aujourd'hui un espace reconnu sur lequel
beaucoup de regards sont vers lequel
beaucoup de regards sont tournés moi je
me félicite de de cette nouvelle
attractivité qu'on a donné à cet espace
un lançant cette consultation citoyenne
je le répète est assez inédite à cette
fois-ci avec une telle ampleur on a déjà
reçu en 3 jours plus de 300 réponses aux
questionnaires par voie électroniques
donc je pense que nous aurons une belle
participation quand on pose les enjeux
d'une manière claire les citoyens sont
au rendez-vous du débat politique et du
débat public alors cette concertation
justement elle va aboutir sur un
résultat vous allez forcément appliquer
le résultat de cette concertation ou
vous gardez une marge de manœuvre la
concertation s'achève le le cette jambe
je respecte les travaux de la commission
extra municipale qui qui s'est réuni qui
est d'ailleurs été présidé par un autre
élu que moi-même un jeune élu en charge
des questions écologiques sous Poissy
kevin fait demain que je remercie pour
son implication et donc si vous voulez
cette Hiéra des douze orientations va
être portée à connaissance de l'état du
département de la région et de l'EPAMSA
pour qu'ils puissent en prendre
compte dans les aménagements qu'on va
décider ensemble mais il était important
que la première marche vers une
réalisation commune soit l'expression
citoyenne ça un engagement que j'avais
pris nous pouvons faire de cette pleine
maraîchère une opportunité écologique et
concertée et dans cette affaire de la
mère de de déchets vous avez porté
plainte contre X justement contre la
pollution au plomb dont est victime de
la ville vous avez jugé que que la ville
justement était victime et qu'elle doit
être dédommagée pour pour cette décision
pour cette histoire en tout cas oui on a
décidé de porter plainte il y a
maintenant un peu plus de deux ans qu'on
X pour mise en danger de la vidéo truie
compte tenu des pollutions aux métaux
lourds sur la plaine et nous sommes
ensuite constitués partie civile en
réclamant un préjudant en dénonçant un
préjudice en Belgique et en demandant
une réparation en faisant appliquer le
principe du pollueur pollueur player
donc on estime ce préjudice écologique à
plus de 80 millions d'euros là où je
suis très satisfait c'est que la plainte
n'a pas été classée puisque une
commission rogatoire est en place et que
le juge a donné instruction à l'office
en charge des problématiques liées aux
pollutions environnementales de se
charger de l'enquête et je serai
prochainement auditionné donc toute
l'occasion pour moi de plaider la cause
de l'environnement et des carrières pour
finir et diète un dernier mot sur les
cigarettes dans les lieux publics
carrière sous Poissy depuis quelques
années à tester en tout cas cette cette
décision aujourd'hui quel bilan est-ce
que vous vous en faites vous avez donc
je le rappelle interdit la possibilité
d'utiliser une cigarette dans diverses
zones de la ville quel bilan ce que vous
faites de décider par arrêter municipal
de créer 40 espaces 10 sans tabacs en
lien avec la Ligue contre le cancer
carrière étant reconnu ville
où se retrouvent les fumeurs ça a lieu
au Japon mais dans plein d'autres pays
et c'est respecté et c'est aussi une
façon d'apprendre à revivre ensemble sur
l'espace public parce que la vraie
problème qu'on a en France aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on considère que l'espace
public est à tout le monde dont il a
personne donc il n'est pas respecté
alors que c'est l'endroit où nous
passons le plus de temps aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup merci à vous et Jay
d'avoir été avec nous j'aurais besoin
que vous êtes le maire de carrière sous
Poissy nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdom politique sur Radio sensation
très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]